[Musique]
même à paysage tranquille
même une prairie avec des vols de cormot
des moissons et des feux derme
[Musique]
même une route où base des voitures des
paysans des coupes même un village pro
vacances avec une foire est un clocher
peuvent conduire tout simplement un camp
de concentration
pendant ce temps burguière ouvrier
allemand stern étudiant juif d'amsterdam
genou le ski marchands de cracovie
annette lycéenne de bordeaux vivent leur
vie de tous les jours sans savoir qu'ils
ont déjà à 1000 kilomètres de chez eux
d'une place assignée et le jour vient où
leurs blogs sont terminées où il ne
manque plus que raflé de varsovie
[Musique]
déporté de l'offre de prague de
bruxelles d'athènes de zagreb d'odessa
ou de rome
[Musique]
interné depuis thiviers
rappelé du vel d'hiv
résistant pas requise à compiègne la
foule des pressions de fait des prix par
erreur des prix au hasard se met en
marche vers les camps
[Musique]
dans le film je pourrais faire un homme
venait le commentateur parle de ig
farben industrie ce d'une compagnie
pourvoyeuse des nazis qui était chargé
de trouver de la main d'oeuvre était
fabriquée d'ailleurs les gaz de gens et
c'est eux qui vont choisir aussi parce
que il fournissait des cobayes pour les
recherches bidon médicale alors on
m'avait choisi quel quai lheureux joie
pour faire une expérience qu'il
expérimentait le la résistance au froid
les gens alors on prenait dans notre
petit quand un bureau du beau blond
prônait une personne une dans la semaine
ou deux on l'emmenait dans un bassin
d'eau glaciale ont trempé la personne
dedans et il ya bien un supposé
scientifiques étaient assis avec akron a
maté puis chronométrer le temps qu'on va
durer
vous comprenez qu'en que je voyais mon
tour arrivé et j'ai tellement remercier
le ciel d'abord voit arriver les
américains qui m'ont libéré
sinon ben oui pascal orvain de parler
vite retrouver la carte des américaines
de votre côté vous avez gaz au tarif
vraiment pas donc ils sont arrivés oui
mais c'est eux qui nous ont sauvés donc
c'était le plus beau jour de ma vie bien
entendu